welcome everyone to seekbar's brilliant
minds bold questions
a five-part virtual event series
exploring questions being addressed by
some of the world's top researchers
each talk pairs speakers from across
disciplines
sectors and the world to explore
questions shaping our future
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions
facing science and humanity my name is
kate getty
and i am senior director of research at
cfar and it's my pleasure to introduce
you to leia cowan
and matt fisher today leia cowan is the
co-director of cfar's fungal kingdom
threats and opportunities program
and associate vice president research at
the university of toronto
and her laboratory takes an
interdisciplinary approach to understand
what allows some microbes to explo
exploit the host and cause disease
and to develop new strategies to treat
life-threatening infectious
diseases matt fisher is a fellow
in seafarer's fundamental kingdom
threats and opportunity program and a
professor at imperial college london
and his research has shown that fungal
pathogens are rapidly increasing in
their impact worldwide
going to unique epidemic epidemiological
features
that allow them to behave as perfect
pathogens
that can drive entire species to
extinction and emerge as novel
human pathogens today's talk
titled what is the next big threat we'll
explore how our interconnected world
is fragile a lesson that has certainly
been brought home through the pandemic
of the last year
and as we start to look to a future
beyond covert 19
we wish to ask what are the next big
threats and what if they come
not from well-studied viruses or
bacteria but from little-known fungi
over the next 30 minutes we'll hear from
two of the world's foremost experts on
fungal pathogens as they discuss how
this long-overlooked kingdom may be
harboring our next
greatest enemy so i'll kick it off by
asking a broad question to our speakers
and we'll let them discuss various
aspects of this theme for about 20
minutes
then we'll take questions from the
audience for roughly 10 minutes
so if you have a question please submit
it through the q a function at the
bottom of your screen and i'll read it
to the speakers
during the session at the end so
to to start us off when we talk about
the fungal kingdom
what are we talking about and why uh why
are we worried
great thanks kate for having us here
we're really thrilled to be here
and that's a great way to start because
most people have no
idea what we're talking about when we're
talking about the fungal kingdom so
to provide a bit of context to start
then really it they're pretty wild these
organisms the best estimates suggest
that they're at least
four million different fungal species
and
as a reference point that's at least six
times as many as there are plant species
these fungi are phenomenally diverse
they include
single-celled tiny organisms that you
can't even see with your naked eye
all the way to the largest organism on
the earth which is
as massive as three blue whales it's
pretty cool for scope and scale
so this fascinating kingdom of organisms
really underpin
all life on earth and it's a great
example of how it's it's rarely about
good versus evil in biology so the
fungal kingdom
presents lots of devastating threats
we're gonna focus on those threats today
but before we tell you more threats in
our universe of threats
we're gonna touch base briefly and share
with you how there's amazing
opportunities in the fungal kingdom so
fungi are
super important for decomposing dead
matter and recycling nutrients
without fungi it's thought that plants
would never have colonized land
fungi engage in really intimate
partnerships that are super important
for about 90
of all land plant species fungi
are also an important source of
nutritious food we know there's at least
350 species that
humans consume as food they're critical
to production of bread some cheeses
alcoholic beverages and about 200
species are also thought to be
hallucinogenic
so we know that fungi also produce a
plethora of different life-saving
medicines
including antibiotics drugs that
modulate immune function and those that
lower cholesterol
we also know that fungi are used to turn
crop waste into biofuel
and they can also eat plastic which is
pretty neat
in fact we think they may even be able
to solve the world's plastic crisis down
the road so
that's great that there's opportunities
and we know of course that there's
threats and that's what we're here
convened for today so i'm going to share
with you one perspective on threat and
then turn it over to matt who's going to
broaden this out and scare everyone
profoundly
so to start then we know in terms of
human health that there's about
200 species that's a small number out of
the 4 million
that are human associated and can cause
lethal disease
they infect billions of people around
the world they kill about 1.5 million
every year so that outpaces mortality
rates for malaria or breast cancer
and is on par with that for tuberculosis
and hiv
and there's really a silent pandemic
right now with the spread of multi-drug
resistant fungal pathogens
which really threatens the effectiveness
of our limited arsenal of anti-fungals
so at that i'm going to turn it over
because we know that fungi have
really profound impacts on many other
aspects of life on our planet and matt
is going to share some of those with us
over to you
hi thanks for that yes i'm i'm talking
to you from st
mary's hospital in london um where
alexander fleming had this uh
serendipitous discovery involving a
bacterium
and the fungus penicillium which
kick-started the antimicrobial
revolution
so fungi are fantastic creatures
but they are also deadly pathogens and
it's no exaggeration to say that they've
caused a male strong
of disease across the 20th century
um they pose a perennial threat to food
security if you manage to deal
with the pestilences that fungi impose
on our crops then you could feed the
bottom
billion of the planet so you know bob
geldof if you're listening
you could feed the world if you manage
to stop the food security
losses that are imposed by fungi and
they also are really potent pathogens to
forests so um in in
north america the chestnut light wiped
out the north american chestnut
the turn of the 20th century and numbers
of species that went along so they
radically rewired that ecosystem
and you know and across europe at the
moment we're witnessing
the loss of the ash trees caused by
another fungus which is exploding across
our
landscapes called calara so ash dieback
is going to
get rid of 12 of the uk's broadleaf ash
forests
and that's of course got really kind of
um huge implications for our ability to
sequester carbon and deal with
you know the mitigating impacts of the
carbon that we have to
rely on our price for but my particular
interest is in fungi as animal pathogens
and they have there i mean obviously
we're all living through covert and we
hate it and we you know
it's it's a terrible pathogen but
literally it's just
nothing on the scale of what a fungus
which
was really motoring along can do so the
worst
ever infection that we've come across is
uh is a fungus it's one of those
small swimming ones um the microscopic
fungus that leia was talking about
called petra kitchen dendrobatis and
that fungus
has exploded across the world and is
driving global amphibian declines
um it's worse than any other pathogen
we've seen because it has caused
so many amphibian extinctions across so
many environments and there are forests
that you can go to and i have gone to
where you don't hear frogs calling
anymore this is a
uh in the rainforest of south america
and australia where the disease was
first detected
so we kind of really you know
i suppose the question we're asking
earlier is you know why
um are we are we seeing all this fungal
disease you know what's
what's different and the sort of lens
that i like to view this
through is this uh is the globalization
big bang
what humanity has done as it's
really got good at trading and um
across the planet and manipulating
environments
and fungi which have these plastic and
fantastic genomes and broadcast ranges
are just really doing well in the
environments that we're um
that we're giving to giving to them and
so that's on one hand they're able to
move
more broadly far and faster
but they also have this um holy trinity
of epidemiological features
so if you i suppose the best way to say
this is
i imagine you may have watched ridley
scott's alien
so there you've got this pathogen that's
sitting there in space
it doesn't care what comes along it can
wait for as long as it wants
but it's there ready and waiting and
you've got no immunity to it
and this is what many fungi do they have
these environmentally resilient stages
which just wait and see they um
the hosts often have no immunity and the
virulence can be 100
whereas if you're thinking about um
covid it's you know
it's it's horrible but it's less than
0.1 so we're really dealing with
um quite in uh implacable foes here
did that scare you enough i i'm good
so i think that's that's wild madden and
just to give that you know some
some color right those spores that can
live for 30 years plus
in the soil and we know that with
coccidioides as an example right which
is
uh broadly found in the american you
know southwest and midwest and
uh there we have huge dust storms that
are amplifying with climate change and
bringing these sports forward for which
we have no vaccine
as i understand it and really very
limited
to no cures available for this so it's
pretty wild and
you know we we know uh what to be
concerned of
of the species we currently know but
there's this whole sort of new paradigm
that we think about in terms
of emerging threats right and emerging
threats
uh has come to the fore really in the
context of kovid we know that
uh when we we don't know what we're
dealing with then we have no
interventions it it can take a
devastating toll
we know that fungi are actually also
causing uh
havoc in the context of covid patients
we know that
uh there's a an emerging issue right now
we're seeing broadly in india with the
black fungus which is a mucor fungus
it's a mold commonly found in soil and
plants and
and even in nasal cavities of healthy
people but it's
seeming to cause sort of huge damage and
even some deadly disease
in recovering covid patients and
partially the underlying defects in
immunity that arise but also the steroid
treatments and other interventions can
really make humans more vulnerable to
many of these
these pathogens so we know that also the
the covid
seems to be making patients more
vulnerable to aspergillus infections
we've seen
outbreaks of another fungus called
canada auris which is a
really cool one as well and i know in
terms of emerging fungi and that you've
done some beautiful work thinking about
where do they come from
and some brilliant detective work of
trying to figure out where are sort of
the hot spots for where the next threats
are coming
so i wonder if you want to share any any
thoughts about sort of
origins or where should we be looking
for some of these deadly emerging
threats yeah so i mean
what you've been alluding to here is
this deep well of biodiversity that
comprises the fungal kingdom and it's
just spectacularly enormous
we really haven't we've described five
percent
of what's out there and
what happens when you you know you start
seeing
amphibians simultaneously dying in
australia and south america you know you
have to ask the question what's the
process here
is it that the frogs are sickening from
some other
um undetected process i mean you were
just talking about
covid there so much mycosis is showing
that
fungal characteristic of just seeking
out a resource
as soon as it opens up and that's
patients who've got covered and diabetes
so perhaps that was what was going on
with the frogs
so what my lab does is we go out there
in the environment and we
let the fungi that's not as easy as it
sounds because
these uh places are often very remote
and actually
for these pathogens are really quite
difficult to culture
um surprisingly so seeing as they you
know they're
to be so deadly and they are but
what we would then do is sequence their
genomes and
the approach that really works when
you're doing these attacking these
global prop
um problems is everyone needs to buy it
and if you have scientists that are
trained in a technique
that you've developed around the world
contributing
items of of the traffic kitchen in this
case
then you have a chance of looking for
genetic genetic characteristics that are
associated with this point of origin
and certainly that was where we got
lucky because we got enough samples from
across the planet
to find the signature of the ancestral
lineage in its heartland which turned
out to be um
south korea and so and
you know using molecular clock estimates
we were then able to show
that the the the frog kitrid had
essentially blasted out of that niche
in the early half of 20th century 20th
century
and is now found across the planet with
you know
these attendant uh losses of
biodiversity and amphibians
and you can kind of recreate that
process for other fungi such as canada
auroras and so on and so on
and through that genomic lens you really
start to appreciate
um where these sources of fungal
biodiversity
are which gives you some eyes on the
problem that you previously didn't have
absolutely i think those are great
points and i and we've alluded to
a lot of interesting themes relevant to
you know how
fungal impacts on the planet have
changed in the anthropocene right or
the period of earth's history where
human activity has really shaped the
planet's climate and ecosystem
i think there's some some really
interesting examples you talked a little
bit about trade
and a little bit about agriculture you
know we think a little bit about how
you know climate change is selecting for
organisms that can grow
at higher temperatures and there's some
really interesting
thinking out there that it's really our
high body temperature that wards off
fungal infections so that's why there's
only a few hundred
fungal species that can currently cause
disease in humans out of the you know
many millions
that that we talked about so we note
then that as as climate
uh change occurs and we have elevated
global temperatures
we're really selecting for fungal
pathogens we're selecting for fungi
that can grow better at higher
temperature we're narrowing that that
window of protection
and we think that that might be what's
happened a little bit with canada auris
right where
we know that in you know 2009 it just
emerged in multiple continents
at really diverse lineages suggesting
that the organism had been around for
quite a long time to accumulate all this
variation
some sort of global selective force
happened and then all of a sudden we see
it really across
across the planet causing disease as a
neat example of how climate change can
really
uh select uh for for new pathogens and
new host ranges
so matt i think a lot about you know
agriculture as well and and how our sort
of monoculture and lack
of genetic variation in some of our
crops really puts us at risk so
i don't know thinking like wheat is a
really cool example of that or bananas
and i wonder if you might want to share
some perspective on those
yeah i mean did you know that the
largest wheat field i learned from
sarah go is 14 000 hectares big
so that there on that field you've got a
monoculture
um which is you know that's if you have
a fungal genotype
some of wheat blast on that then you
really have a problem
so because the just the power of
amplifying that
genotype is so high so you know
obviously
intensive agriculture of that magnitude
you have to use
chemicals on an unparalleled scale to
to for crop protection and
looking at the recent um azole usage
uh for the united states the increases
in
and azole azol's are the kind of primary
crop protectant against some fungi
those uh there's those increases are a
spiraling
they're almost exponential in the amount
of usage that's
being needed to do to protect crops
these days that's just testament to how
the fungi are evolving away from the
crop protection and then
that's spilling over into the you know
when you have
the off target from into fungi that
affect humans
say aspergillus fumigatus which is in
every breath you take
then yeah if you if you are immune
suppressed then your clinician
has got a uh has got a problem and you
know you work with doctors
who who deal with these fine these
infections on a daily basis and that
they're not they're not easy infections
to treat
aren't they no absolutely so
so many interesting threats and it you
know in context
it's interesting because we can look at
the really broad history of
of our planet i kind of look back you
know 66
million years ago and think about how
fungi may have really
changed the entire distribution of
species and
you know there's some interesting models
out there i wonder if
uh do you want to share some thoughts on
on the impact of fungi
in context of dinosaurs and mammals and
and anything yeah i mean so you know and
you you alluded to it with our body
temperature is 37 degrees and that's
that's a major hurdle for your
for your your average fungus you know
there are about 200
that um we know presently that are able
to do that
so yes so the the it's called the um
this ancient fungal catastrophe is the
fungal infection the male and selective
hypothesis
and it's an argument for why there are
no dinosaurs left on the planet
so the argument runs like this 65
million years ago
a meteorite struck the planet
and caused a global cooling event so at
that point
the major vertical biodiversity was
dinosaurs and their body temperature
dipped at the same time that all the
forest died and essentially a compost
earth was created
so those decomposing fungi that produced
billions of spores overwhelmed the
immunosuppressed dinosaurs
but not the little squirrely mammals
that were in the undergrowth
that had high body temperatures and so
you know
that compost earth opened up a vast
ecological niche
that the you know the warm mammals were
able to radiate into and you know
here we are the rest is history so cool
it's a it's a it's a wonderful and there
is actually experimental evidence
because
there's the line of fungal spores at the
kt boundary so
you know the geologists are in on this
particular hypothesis as well
absolutely so i think kate has just uh
appeared so that tells me there's a
transition and i'll turn it over to kate
to help us
guide through this yeah wonderful leah
and matt that's
that's a fantastic introduction and
summary of
what we understand so far um i'm going
to
we've been getting some questions and
i'll remind other audience members if
you have any questions please
feel free to type them in the q a
section um
but maybe i'll even just start with the
question that we
put at the outset or the the title that
we get to the talk which is
what is the next big threat and um
from what i've been hearing you say so
far it sounds like
we don't know is is that fair
i would say that's that's what we what
what we say is we know
there will be a next big threat posed by
a fungal kingdom i would you know i have
absolutely no doubt
just going on past experience and the
accelerating trends that we're seeing
uh you know fungi will evolve to every
control method that we
um you know impose on them currently
and also they're going to respond to
these anthropocene drivers that we're
that we're giving them so it's you know
it's really up to people like leia to
come up with
new and very funky ways of um of
of combating this emerging threat
because we don't know what it is
absolutely so kate i wonder if we could
build one of the questions in which was
just is there sort of high throughput
massively parallel ways to screen for
anti-fungals so yeah
that's where i was going to go next go
ahead do you want me to work so
i'll read out the question because it's
actually from when that stefar's other
co-director of the learning machines and
brains program but he asks if there are
known ways to massively screen candidate
antifungals
um for example uh using synthetic
biology to generate
many such candidates and if so can ai be
of use
yes and yes and i would love to work
with you so that's how we open it
so we do tons of that kind of work in my
lab that's actually
our general approach to biology is we do
huge large scale
both chemical biology screens so
screening really large collections of
really diverse molecules so
300 000 compound collections you know of
that kind of scale so whether that's
massive enough
that's uh it's where we're starting and
we skin really different kinds of
libraries of molecules some of them are
natural products where we think these
molecules are tuned over the course of
evolution they're produced by organisms
to have biological effects so we screen
natural products we screen
synthetic molecules and we do all kinds
of really elegant screens to find those
that can either kill the fungus or can
abolish drug resistance or can
specifically
impair or disable virulence mechanisms
or the ability to cause disease
so depending on the kinds of screens we
get really different kinds of molecules
we can also take sort of a genetic based
approach where we're building these
really large-scale
mutant collections where we can take out
every single gene
individually in the organism's genome or
reduce the levels of the gene product
and by doing so we can identify all of
the genes that are required for the
pathogen to survive
all of them that are required for drug
resistance or causing disease
and then by linking those two approaches
we can figure out which molecules target
those interesting gene products
and then sort of optimize programs to
really engineer
fungal selective molecules because a
challenge is that fungi are actually
much
closer related to animals than they are
to plants even though it may not look
like it
but their cell walls are made of
something called chitin which is
actually
lobster shells again much closer to
animals
so a key challenge is really once we get
these interesting molecules is making
sure that they're really selective to
kill the fungus
and not take down the host along along
with it
so we do those screens and definitely
amenable to ai to be able to learn the
rules for
you know what's required to get
molecules inside of fungi they have
thick walls and active
machinery to pump stuff out of cells so
definitely amenable and
uh we're really interested in working in
that space
terrific thanks for that answer leia um
there are
a number of questions i think just
trying to get a sense of the
scope of um threat to humans and
one of the questions has been for
example why does the world not
know more about deaths due to fungal
infections
um or maybe put another way is the rate
of fungal devastation increasing every
year or is it that we're more
aware due to advances in research
matt do you want to leave with that one
yeah i mean
fungi do they are devastating um
diseases and they you know they're
they're on
par with malaria and tb um in the
in the mortality and burden disease that
they cause
what's different about fungi is it's
very hard to know
what to do with them and this is where
advocacy for the problem
kind of falls off they're they're a
polyglot group there's lots of different
fungal infections
um they're opportunistic and
environmental so often you know
uh a good example of that is we first
recognized
um and learned about hiv aids because of
a rare fungal infection which started
appearing in the game in san francisco
that was pneumocystis
so it's a it's an underlying marker of
um
of of another of another problem so to
deal with pneumocystis you really have
to deal with hiv aids
um so that's so that's that's that's a
you know another another problem but i
think there's generally just a lack of
a lack of appreciation and advocacy in
the general
general epidemiological area in public
health arena
which is changing quite rapidly as fungi
move into
cdc databases and world health
organization
antimicrobial resistance surveillance
programs so
this this is being addressed at the
moment
um i know leia you can see the questions
as well there are
it's wonderful i mean i think it speaks
to the the breadth of
researchers that you brought together in
the super fungal uh kingdom program as
well covering the the
the span from from agricultural to human
health to
um you know the biodiversity work that
you
uh that you work on matt sorry i've just
lost my questions do you want to
read one from the the q a yourself are
you able to see them
yeah i mean maybe one of the the
questions that was up at the beginning
was looking at sort of
antimicrobial resistance and and
superbugs and had the potential to send
us back to an era where simple
infections could kill
with the current use of so many
antibiotics antifungals
due to complications rising from covet
infections
what role could this play in dealing
with you know in the future more fatal
outbreaks so for antifungals you know
those that we can use to treat
systemic fungal infections so invasive
infections we have so
few we have three different classes of
antifungals to treat these invasive
infections
that is not a lot that is compared to
several dozen classes of antibacterials
where we still have a huge
you know looming crisis with antibiotic
resistance
so part of the challenge is again that
fungi are so closely related to humans
so it's really really challenging
to develop drugs that selectively kill
the fungus another part of the challenge
is that there's been a lack of
investment in this space and it's an
understudied underfunded area so it's a
huge you know importance and that's why
we've assembled this team to really
tackle
this kind of grand challenge but part of
it is also
as matt alluded to the really wide use
we you know we have three classes and
one of them is used incredibly broadly
in agriculture
so matt i know you've been tracking this
with looking at how you know the
the use of you know thousands of tons of
azoles in agriculture has selected for
resistance that can then spread to the
clinic i don't know if you want to
touch on that yeah i mean that's this is
the problem of dual use
you know because there's so many so few
opportunities um chemically speaking to
to deal with fungi
both the agriculturalists and the
clinicians use the same class
of drugs often and asol's
i use millions millions of tons a year
both in the in that in agriculture in
the clinic and you know
if you're in the environment and you
evolve resistance there and you get into
a patient then it's a very hard
infection to treat so this is why we
need
people like leia and allowed to go forth
and actually find something different
and the chat actually did mention rna
and there's a lot of really exciting
movements in the rna's
eye space so um you know with um we look
we're looking forward to a bright future
in terms of those new therapies it's
amazing and just to maybe add i know
we're close to time here kate but
the kinds of things we do by bringing
together really different people is
is amazing so we've got people working
on you know
vaccine for the bats right who would
have thought about that
that's totally wild that talked about a
fungus that's killing off bats i think
earlier
and that that's a huge issue and we had
a
pediatrician a fungal pediatrician who's
an expert on infectious disease
who teamed up uh with a wildlife
biologist
and you know brilliant story about these
people who came together brought
together these really different areas of
expertise
and have done incredible work and they
have a vaccine that looks like it could
help save the bats from this deadly
fungus
and they can deliver it on the surface
of the bats backs and then they groom
each other and ingest it i mean it's
it's totally amazing so i think that's
uh how we're dealing with all these sort
of unknown
threats is we just bring together
incredible people who are
you know all eyes are focused on
on what's happening around us and
figuring out where are these threats and
how do we best tackle them
well thank you so much larry matt for
sharing your insights with
with us today i'm afraid that's all that
we have time for
um for everyone who's joined us thank
you as well uh
please visit our website cpr.ca to find
out more about
this series and to view recordings of
previous talks and the recording from
this talk will be posted
early next week thank you all take care
[Music]
you